6 25 on your friday morning last week
and cool at school we told you about a
team of junior high school kids winning
a robotics competition now how about a
team of young women who want a different
robotics event
my name is zelia i'm diana i'm emma i'm
mia i'm kennedy and i'm nadya this group
of seventh and eighth graders from the
pinecrest academy's sloan canyon campus
call themselves the amazons their robot
the quacken won the robot skills
champion award at the state level zelia
says the goal of the challenge was to
collect the balls from the field and
shoot them into the goal and while that
worked great it was the team's
successful participation in the optional
bio mimicry competition that guaranteed
them a spot in the world championships
in dallas in may hey amazon emma what's
biomimicry
according to the biomimicry institute
biomimicry is a practice that learns
from and mimics the strategies found in
nature to solve human design challenges
they brainstormed researched and
designed a robot to expand what's
currently being done in search and
rescue efforts after building collapses
it's small and flexible for easy
navigation it's also equipped with
several touch distance and ultrasonic
sensors in order to collect and send
back information and video about the
class this will help search and rescue
locate missing people and decide where
they should or shouldn't send an actual
workers
wow i mean when i was in seventh grade i
was concerned about what was for lunch
these kids are out to change the world
so the amazons they are just one of six
teams already coached by anna egbert
they're all looking for a little help
from the community as they work towards
an estimated fifty thousand dollars
needed to send forty students and six
chaperones on the trip to dallas in may
well the amazons have already earned
fifteen hundred dollars by holding a
sold out robotics camp for elementary
students this afternoon we've got a link
to their donation page and our website
eight newsnow 8newsnow.com you know some
that's cool at school let us know we're
under the community tab newsnow.com or
just email cool at school at
8newsnow.com which will be right back